- How to stay fit and healthy
while working at a full-time job.
This is a question that so many
of us are asking ourselves.
And I know from my time
working in McKinsey,
how difficult it can be to
manage the high pace job,
the whole workload with staying healthy,
with keeping to your
daily health routines.
Today I have something very
special for you because
I have a guest here with me,
I have Marie here with me,
who is a true expert on
living the healthy life.
I know you will love her.
You will take so much value
out of all the tips
that she will give you.
But to start properly, welcome
to my channel, Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich, and
this is the right place
for all the tips, tricks, and strategies
to be successful in the
first years of your career.
As always, if you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
and I know that you will this time,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe to my channel
for even more content from me.
I will release at least
one video every Sunday.
And if you want to see
even more content from me,
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is @FirmLearning.
There I'm releasing new content
pretty much every single day for you.
And on my Instagram channel,
I made a little survey.
I asked you guys whether
you struggle as well
with keeping a balance between
working at a full-time job
and also staying fit, exercising,
and doing all these things
that we all know are so important.
And I must say, the results
surprised me a little bit
because over 80% of you said that,
yes I do struggle with this as well.
So this gives me some
hope because apparently
I'm not the only one who
struggles with these things.
And this tells me that probably this video
was even more necessary that I thought.
So I'm very excited for
what is about to come
for this great interview,
looking forward to that.
Thanks for watching as well
and let's get right into it.
So here I am back and
I'm having Marie with me.
Marie, thank you for being here.
This is so amazing to have you today.
So Marie, maybe you just want
to briefly introduce yourself.
Who are you, what qualifies you
to speak about these topics?
- Thanks for having me Heinrich.
Hi everyone, I'm Marie and I used to work
in a law firm and worked 80 hours a week.
And I know the struggles
of having and establishing
a very healthy lifestyle,
especially for those
who don't want to be very
stressed or depressed
and struggle on how to establish
a very healthy lifestyle.
- That's amazing, but
there's more than that right?
I think you also wrote a
book or something like that?
- Oh yeah, I did write
a book, or two books.
One book on establishing
a healthy lifestyle,
including a lot of recipes for you.
And then also a time management book
but that's not the topic of today's video.
- That's amazing and
I'm sure that in the end
maybe we also have some
opportunity to maybe even also
show the book and maybe you
can say a few words on that.
But I'd say before that,
let's directly jump into the topic, right?
So here on my channel, we talk all about
how to be successful in the
first years of your career,
and of course for all of us,
for all these viewers out there,
it's just so important also
to get these two things
under one head, on the one hand side,
of course the high pays job
but then also the healthy life.
What are the dimensions,
what are the things
you are thinking about when
getting your life in order?
What do you believe are
the relevant things here?
- So I would say there are four topics.
The four topics start
with a morning routine,
which I will describe later on.
Then obviously working out, and then food.
So food is a very, very important part
of a very healthy lifestyle.
And the last one is sleep.
I know you do get too little
sleep but if you maybe cut
one or two things, maybe
you do have some more sleep.
- Then I'd say, that's a perfect (mumbles)
almost as if you already
(mumbles), it's amazing.
But then let's start with the
morning routine, actually.
So, frankly, I tried
that a couple of times,
to do some yoga or some
meditation in the morning,
but I miserably failed
with all these things
most of the time.
So what are the components
that you would recommend
for a morning routine
and do you have some tips
on how to make these things
actually stick to your life?
- I mean, those are two different topics.
So what I do suggest, is that
you start with baby steps.
Every routine starts with
establishing maybe one step,
and then you can go from
one step to the second step.
So, my first step would
always include drinking
a warm glass of water
with some lemon juice.
And I know a lot of you guys,
you stay in four and five star hotels,
every hotel has some lemon juice
and if they don't have
some fresh lemon juice,
they do have those sachets
with some lemon juice
and you can just pour it
in a warm glass of water,
or if you don't have a water
bottle on your hotel room,
you can just take a glass
of sink water, tap water.
Lemon water is important for you
because it boosts your metabolism
and starts your metabolism,
so it's really important
to start your day, not by
drinking something cold
because it actually shocks your stomach,
but drinking something
warm to welcome the day.
- Oh I didn't know that, interesting.
Okay so warm glass with lemon juice,
is there something more to it?
- No, actually that's it.
And then obviously the
morning routine would include
a small workout, but then we're already
at the workout section.
You do not always have
to include your workout
in the morning, but I would
suggest you to include
in the morning because in the evening,
that's my impression then you're too tired
and you're too stressed,
and probably your partner
or project leader demands
a lot of time of you.
So, do it in the morning,
and I promise you will feel
much better and refreshed.
- That's interesting.
Personally I have to say for me,
it always felts so much more difficult
to workout in the morning
than in the evening,
but I guess that's maybe also a question
of your personality type and preference.
But okay, your recommendation
is to do it in the morning.
Any other things, what
other elements are core
to a good morning routine
from your perspective?
- I mean obviously it does
include getting up a bit earlier
than you tend to get up.
So probably the most of you
have a lifestyle where they
try to sleep the much they can,
so their timer maybe
gets up at 7:00 or 8:00,
and then you just have a
short shower and then you rush
down to the buffet and you
just stuff into the food,
and then you head to the client.
- Yeah, that was me for years, for sure.
- So what I would recommend,
just maybe start by getting up
a half an hour earlier, then
drink your warm glass of water,
and then maybe just do 20 minutes.
And I promise you, once
you establish that routine,
you will feel the differences.
- Yeah, I understand.
There's also all this whole
element of mindfulness,
right, just in the morning
not starting the day off
completely rushed and stressed already
because you're already late
and your timer just went on
a couple of minutes
later than you hoped for.
And just, is this a thing, mindfulness?
What can you do without a big
time invested in the morning
to start off the day in a mindful way?
- I do always include a
very short meditation.
I know it's a lot to ask of you to start,
to include a workout and also
that warm glass of water.
- But the warm glass of
water, that's quick, right?
- Yeah okay, okay, so then maybe start
with five minutes of meditation.
And my tip for good
meditation is try to find
a very quiet seat, and
then close your eyes
and do a body scan.
If you are interested in that body scan
I can link you some
interesting videos on that.
- I think that's gonna do for
sure, so we're gonna then link
a few key resources that
Marie recommends below.
But interesting concept, okay good.
So that's the morning routine,
anything else you'd like to add to that?
- I think that's it for now.
- So let me summarize then,
it's the warm glass of
water with the lemon juice,
it's some basic exercise which
you're going to talk about
more in minute about,
and then it's also some more meditation,
five minutes or so for some
basic mindfulness exercise,
something it doesn't matter
how late last night was,
doesn't matter how busy we are,
we can always find the time
for drinking a certain glass
of warm water and also
five minutes of meditation.
But now of course, the
next thing is exercise.
And now you also said that
you would like to recommend
that to do that in the morning.
I mean when I exercise,
that can easily take
30 minutes, 60 minutes,
that is quite a big time
invested in the morning, right?
- That's true, that's totally true.
You don't have to invest 30 to 60 minutes.
There are a lot of
disbeliefs that you need
a lot of time for working out,
and to have a good workout
you have to workout long, that's wrong.
Already, if you do body weight exercises
it doesn't have to be a run,
it can just be maybe some exercises
on a YouTube channel you like,
where you use some body weight.
A very good exercise I would
always suggest is planking
because it stabilizes your
back muscles and obviously
is good for you sitting very,
very long hours on a project.
Or maybe some push-ups which
are really beneficial as well,
or sit-ups.
- So how much time do you need to invest
from your recommendation in the morning,
so what is the time budget
that you should take here?
- I would recommend start with
15 to 20 minutes everyday.
I mean obviously if you
don't do it everyday
in the beginning, it's not that bad.
But just starting a routine
is really beneficial for you.
- Yeah, to sum that up it
would be 15 to 20 minutes
of exercise, then five
minutes of meditation,
then drinking a glass of
water so probably what,
mean an investment of about half an hour,
which I know can be sometimes quite tough
if you really work super
late in the evening,
but then probably half an
hour to just start your day
in the right mood just to make
sure that you're setup right,
probably the long-term that
really will be worth your time,
right?
- Exactly, I mean there
are lot of people that
after a long workday, they
check their social media,
and if I can make one suggestion,
cut the social media usage.
I know it's very addictive
and obviously makes fun
to check your Instagram
stories or any Facebook posts.
I know that, but out
of your five day week,
or maybe a four day week at the client,
just cut the four days and
you still have three days
where you can binge on Instagram.
- Though of course there's one exception
and this is watching videos on my channel.
That of course you should always do.
But yes, I completely (mumbles) always.
But that's a good point.
How I always thought
about that when I worked
at McKinsey Data Science, is that,
I always try to get three units
of longer exercise sessions.
And now I heard from Marie
that she recommended doing
little session every
single morning, right,
probably more to get you started,
to get your metabolism up
than really to do some serious training.
But I always hoped to do
three sessions on top of that.
And what I always did was
Friday, so on Friday evening
usually I was able to get
of the office a bit earlier,
so then that for sure was a session.
And then also either
Saturday or Sunday I would go
for a second session, and then
there was only one session
that I needed to somehow
fit within the workweek of,
let's say, Monday to Thursday.
And my perception here was that somehow,
if I really wanted to, it
was always possible, right?
So it doesn't matter how
tough the project was,
how difficult it was,
there was always some time.
For me it was in the evening
because that was just
my personal preference, to
get maybe a one hour run in
on Tuesday or Wednesday or so.
I would almost always able
to then discuss (mumbles)
associate with my Project
Lead, with my Team Lead,
just to get the time in.
And then maybe that would
mean that maybe I only had
a very quick dinner or no dinner at all.
Or maybe then afterwards
I went back to my desk
and then continued working,
but getting the little exercise unit in,
that was always possible
from my experience.
- Yeah, yeah definitely.
So that's a good routine
that you established,
always having three workouts a week.
I mean, if you have one day in a week
in your four days of project
work, and everybody knows,
especially your boss knows,
then that's a reason that
the boss will leave you alone
at that time.
So if the boss knows, okay
Heinrich goes running at 7:00 pm
and he always goes running
at 7:00 pm on a Monday,
he knows that's your holy time.
And everyone, also your
colleagues will leave you alone.
- And I think, I completely agree Marie.
How I always did it, especially
when I was an Associate
in one side and was the Project Leader,
of course you maybe will
have a bit more flexibility
to organize your day,
but in the beginning of the project,
I always made sure to
have such a conversation
with my Project Lead, with my Team Lead,
that kind of a two-sided conversation,
what was really important to me in terms
of the way of working and
handling all these things,
and what was important
to the Project Lead.
And at least at McKinsey,
there was a bit of
kind of structure, just a standardized way
of having these conversations, right,
so this was quite typical.
But then I always made it
clear that it was just very
important for me to get a
proper unit of longer exercise
in once every week from
Monday to Thursday,
and I always try to pick one day
to make that stick and
to make everybody know.
And then from my experience,
even though of course
the characters of Project Leads
and so on can be quite different, right,
but from my experience there
was always the possibility
to kind of discuss this and agree
with the Project Lead of
that, and from my experience
it's just important just to be explicit.
Just make it really clear
that this is your expectations
as Associate to be able to do that,
and usually you will find
that people will agree.
There should be an opportunity
once a week to carve an hour
of sports out of your evening
or of your morning, right?
So people will agree and
this will be possible,
but it's also a matter
of you demanding that,
of you making it clear that
this is really important to you.
Just my two cents on that.
- Yeah, great.
- No, good, so that's exercise.
So let's now jump to the
third topic, and this is food.
And I know this is a topic
you're especially passionate about.
- Exactly.
So in my book I promote the vegan,
gluten free, and no sugar lifestyle.
I know this sounds very strange
for maybe a lot of you guys.
And I don't recommend every
one of you to cut everything
from one day to the other.
I know Heinrich, you love your
steak and you love your meat.
- I do.
- But what I would recommend
for everyone who has some time.
You don't really need a
lot of time to eat healthy.
Is maybe start with cutting the sugar.
I know especially on a very long workday,
those chocolate bars
are very tempting, yeah?
And obviously the longer you
work, the better they taste.
- So let's talk about a
typical day of somebody working
in a law firm or in a consulting firm
or a busy corporate job.
What would you recommend them to eat
at the different times of the day?
- So I would have three big meals.
I would start with
breakfast, which is oatmeal
and keeps you full for a couple of hours.
Then I would eat a light lunch,
maybe some salad with some proteins.
And maybe something warm in the evening,
if you do have the time
to eat something warm.
And as a snack, I would
include two snacks.
I would include some nuts
and some dried fruit.
- Why nuts?
- They're especially good
for your brain health.
So I would recommend eating walnuts,
if you're not allergic to them obviously.
They're very, very good
for your brain health.
- Good.
And just to second that, right,
so especially these
snacks in the team room.
I mean this is such a trap, right?
There are so many experiences
that I had in team room
where people just
started to buy chocolate,
just leave it there for
everybody just to eat.
And this is just so difficult
then to resist the temptation.
And from my experience, in the end,
what it always came down to,
if you want to change that,
was always up to one
person in the team then
just to stand up and say hey guys,
let's not have these
chocolate snacks all the time.
But let's get some other snacks.
And just somebody taking the initiative
and then organizing some other
stuff from the supermarket
around next corner or whatever
your opportunities are
from wherever your workplace
is or wherever the client was.
So why shouldn't that be you right?
So just take the initiative
if you believe that your team
is developing really unhealthy
habits which then, of course,
often leads also to
yourself eating unhealthy.
Take the initiative yourself
and just make an impact.
Say that you want to change
that and then trust me,
everybody on the team
will be grateful for that.
- Yeah, exactly.
So what I promote in my book
is a vegan, gluten free,
and no added sugar lifestyle.
And obviously those chocolate
bars do count to sugar
so just maybe standup
and tell your teammates
no chocolate bars any longer.
And if it's some bars then
maybe it's the very healthy
nut bars you can buy in
the supermarket as well.
- This is also one of my experiences.
I just remember one team I had,
we developed this habit of
pretty much once a week or so
we just bought from the
supermarket a huge box of nut bars.
And maybe then they also had
a little bit of chocolate
on there but not like
a full chocolate bar.
But, probably this wasn't the
most healthy snack out there.
But it was much better
than these huge bars
of chocolate or candy that
you just unfortunately have
so often in these team rooms.
- But be careful.
I know it's a good thing
to start with nut bars.
There are a lot of nut bars,
especially in supermarkets,
that include a lot of sugar.
Maybe just turn the nut bar around
and then look for added sugar.
That's the thing you always
want to look out, added sugar.
If it's naturally included,
it's not that bad for you.
- Yeah, we don't want added sugar.
Okay, that's some great
insights into the food.
Let's now come to sleep.
I mean, and again, this is
just such a difficult topic,
you're just chronically,
constantly sleeping not enough
unfortunately you're on so many projects.
Do we have any suggestions what you can do
to maybe just improve the
quality of your sleep?
Or just the, still then, nevertheless,
the extent of your sleep?
What are your suggestions on that?
- Okay, so obviously I cannot
change your working hours.
That's something you can't change
and if your partner demands
that slide to be finished maybe
at 2:00 am in the morning,
obviously you cannot say no.
- Well I would not
necessarily agree with that,
I think there are some ways
you can push back also on that,
but maybe that's a
topic for another video,
but let's just assume
you cannot change it.
- Okay, so obviously
then a lot of you guys
take out their phone when
they're already in bed
and then they start checking messages.
This is something I would cut.
It's proven that if you check your phone
and also check a screen directly
before you start sleeping,
your sleep is much
worse than if you don't.
So, if it's possible for
you, try to half an hour
before you go to sleep, not
check any screens any longer, A.
And B, try to meditate for
five minutes before you sleep.
Sit down in your hotel
room, close your eyes,
and then do a body scan.
And when you sleep, what
is also really healthy
and what promotes good sleep is lavender,
maybe a lavender oil, you
can rub on your temples.
And lavender is proven
to promote good sleep.
- Okay, I've never tried that
but maybe we'll try that in the future.
Good.
Just two things also just
adding from my experience
working in consulting, what
I felt was really helpful,
two tips, so first,
in the early years of
working in consulting,
I just drank so much coffee all day,
even until late in the evening,
and I just was convinced that
it didn't really effect me
in the sense that I
was still able to sleep
even though I just drank several cups
of coffee or anything like that.
What I then realized over time
is that, while it was true,
while it was correct that
I was still able to sleep,
somehow I realized that
the quality of my sleep
lacked a bit, right?
And then I did a bit of
research and I found out that
the half period time of caffeine can take
up to four to five hours,
and I found that quite insane, right?
So this means if you have
a cup of coffee at 6:00 pm
in the evening, that means
that then around midnight,
you still have half of
the caffeine in your body.
And that really made me thinking,
that made me realize
that probably I shouldn't
drink coffee or take in
other sources of caffeine
in the afternoon, so I usually
try after 3:00 pm, 4:00 pm,
not drink any coffee anymore.
And at least subjectively, I
felt that my sleep improved.
And the second tip that
I develop over time,
I found out over time,
that for me it really helps
to put the smartphone on
airplane mode while I sleep.
And not sure why exactly, I'm
not sure if this is because
all the frequencies that
maybe don't happen anymore,
I'm not sure if there's any
scientific rationale for that
or maybe it's just knowing
that the phone will not disturb you,
that nobody will call you at
night or anything like that.
But just having the phone on
airplane mode, at least for me
it really improved my
sleep quality over time.
- Great idea, Heinrich.
- Good.
So anything you'd like to add on that?
- No I think that's one
section obviously as well.
Try to reduce your coffee intake,
rather drink some green tea
instead of the caffeine.
But I think everyone can
handle that the way they like.
- Yeah perfect.
So, I think this now has been
quite a comprehensive discussion.
So we talked about morning routines,
we talked about exercising,
about food, about sleep.
So thank you very much, Marie.
But now also I'd like to
give you this opportunity
just to introduce your new book a bit.
What is it, tell us about it.
- Thanks, so this is my new book.
You can buy it on Amazon as a
print on demand or an eBook.
So if you're on your job,
then you can maybe download it
on your Kindle or maybe your iPhone.
And yeah, it does include a lot of recipes
that are very, very healthy
such as some oatmeal,
some almond mousse, or some porridge.
And then maybe how to start your day.
Here you see the lemon water,
as I already discussed.
And obviously book two
is already in the making,
so I hope you will buy my
book and I hope you like it.
- I can completely second
that and it's a great book.
I read it myself and of
course will leave a link
to the book below in the video
description, so check it out.
And thank you, Marie!
That's it, I really appreciate
to hear this interview with you.
I think there were some
really great and tangible tips
that we all can profit from.
So again, if you took any
value out of the video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
to help this video be found
by many more people as well.
And please also subscribe to my channel
for even more content
on how to be successful
in the first years of your career.
So thank you again, Marie.
Thank you all of you watching out there,
I really appreciate your time.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning
and see you next Saturday.